this trip to europe has been a complete
total disaster
it's sad it's embarrassing it's
humiliating but joe biden pictured as
you can see there taking a little nappy
poo
in public during a meeting about climate
change now joe just couldn't seem to
keep his eyes open peacefully sleeping
not a care in the world and then of
course an aide has to rush over about uh
joe
hello joe joe joe wake up joe
this is the latest humiliating moment
out of biden
i guess donald trump was right sleepy
joe living up to his name now this week
when biden wasn't dozing off he was busy
apologizing including a blanket apology
to europe for america's evil ways
the same america that saved europe
let me let me figure that out
while you watch this
i guess i shouldn't apologize but i do
apologize for the fact the united states
uh
the last administration pulled out of
the paris accords and put us sort of
behind
ball
really joe it was the united states of
america we saved europe and the world
joe biden and under donald trump net
emissions carbon emissions went down and
went down dramatically as a matter of
fact joe donald trump led every single
country in reducing carbon output so
instead of joe biden apologizing to
europe he ought to be showing them how
we did it also joe you pushed our
western european allies right into that
hostile actor vladimir putin's arms
giving vladimir that special pipeline
waiver while simultaneously taking away
high-paying career jobs for americans on
the keystone xl pipeline other energy
industry jobs great job joey and now
he's reduced our supply of oil and gas
and at the very same time now for the
second time he is begging opec and saudi
arabia and the middle east and vladimir
putin to pump more oil senator barrasso
says we get more oil from putin than we
are getting from alaska does that make
any sense take a look
when the cost of a gallon of gasoline
gets to above 330 or 300 3.35 cents a
gallon it has profound impact on working
class families just to get back and
forth to work
so i don't see anything inconsistent
with that but i do think that the idea
that
russia and saudi arabia and other major
producers are not going to pump more oil
so people can have gasoline to get to
and from work for example is uh is is is
is
not is not right but uh and what we're
considering doing that i'm reluctant to
say before i have to do it
joe you got rid of energy independence
that donald trump handed you you
single-handedly reduced the supply on
the world market because you went with
new green deal radical socialism here's
a question does that make any sense from
an economic standpoint a national
security perspective an environmental
perspective producing less oil here at
home and then import more oil and you're
concerned about climate change well if
the oil is being pumped here instead of
there and we get it cheaper when we pump
it here it's going to still have the
same net effect on the environment and
on the planet earth that you love so
much and by the way now we have to go to
countries that hate our guts and beg
them to produce more oil because you
artificially reduced our supply because
that's exactly what is happening right
now thanks to joe or joe's handlers or
whoever's making the decision these days
more pollution higher costs fewer
american jobs but don't expect joe to
have to answer any tough questions about
any of this because during his only
press conference in europe biden once
again first said i'm not allowed to talk
i get they get mad at me and everything
and then said all right i'll call on a
small list of support reporters
pre-selected pre-screened as per usual
by his staff you can't make this up joey
you're the president you get to decide
please sit down i apologize for keeping
you waiting we were
playing with elevators
long story anyway
good evening and now i'm happy to take
some questions and i'm told i should
start with ap
zeke miller zeke you have a question
i didn't recognize you the max on mascon
i apologize
i'm told i should start
joey
you're the president joe you get to
decide your staff shouldn't be making
that decision for you
right now america is fast facing slow
economic growth record-setting inflation
a massive worker shortage in part
because of your policies a supply chain
fiasco because of your policies high
energy prices which means everybody's
paying more for everything a crisis you
caused at america's border americans you
abandoned in afghanistan but joe biden
is either unwilling unable to have a
lengthy open unscripted discussion with
the press
and according to a new nbc news poll 71
percent of you the american people
believe the country is headed in the
wrong direction including a majority of
democrats get this npr
marist poll finds a plurality of
democrats think that replacing biden in
2024 will give them a better shot at
winning they're not wrong the numbers
are so bad that even one of msdnc's top
democrats chucky todd he's trying to
sound the alarm listen
good sunday morning happy halloween we
have a brand new nbc news poll out this
morning that's filled with some scary
news for the democrats the overarching
message americans have lost their
confidence in president biden and their
optimism for the country at least they
have right now just 22 percent of adults
say we're headed in the right direction
a shocking 71 percent say we're on the
wrong track and that includes a near
majority of democrats republicans
believe it or not have double-digit
leads in dealing with border security
inflation
crime national security the economy
and shockingly on getting things done
even more shocking 22 percent of
americans think the country is going in
the right direction
what what direction is right now there's
no plan whatsoever to fix any of the
biden administration's self-inflicted
crises for example the administration's
seemingly
you know their only plan to fix the
supply chain is just call fedex we get
lectured again to call fedex oh i guess
we should lower our thermostats and put
our sweaters on and go right back to
jimmy carter's malaise factor here's
biden's commerce secretary over the
weekend
there are reports that those while the
president announced the 24 7 opening
that that's not actually happening out
in california that there's still backups
business community has been complaining
about that there are backups and as i
said this isn't something that can be
fixed overnight but the important thing
is you know fundamentally supply chains
and logistics are run by the private
sector you know people say to me will
christmas gifts be delivered to which i
say
call fedex you know that that isn't what
the government does
oh let me translate you have no plan
you're on your own shop in october for
christmas settle for less pay more
unless of course you're an illegal
immigrant then you get special rules
applied to you as a matter of fact you
thought it was bad when they're not
covered testing or having a vaccine
mandate preferential treatment for
illegal immigrants well now you'll love
this as we told you last week the biden
administration is now
out there with a plan to give certain
illegal immigrants
450 000
each for their pain and their suffering
pain and suffering by the way that they
caused themselves because they didn't
buy they decided to violate our laws and
not respect our borders and our
sovereignty that i guess is fairness in
the minds of the joe biden democratic
socialist party and by the way it's only
one small part of the biden
administration's plan to spend trillions
and trillions of dollars on this new
green deal
social welfare build back worst program
of his that will cause back-breaking
stagflation transform the country into a
socialist train wreck it's why
every single election national state and
local is important and especially
tomorrow in virginia new jersey
americans can send a very important
message we can begin the process of
getting this country back on track you
have to go to the polls you have to show
up hey sean hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else